sejam bem-vindos a mais um vídeo eu
recebi esta coisa à porta de casa penso
eu que seja macumba macumbaria alguém
quer fazer de mal aqui ao Dark não é
bastante Provável que seja alguma coisa
do inscrito ok Porque eu recebi esta
coisa a porta de casa há cerca de um ano
atrás e esta caixa eu recebi após ter
feito aquele vídeo da boneca assombrada
então é bastante provável que tenha sido
um inscrito mesmo mas vamos ver o que
tem aqui dentro eu vou deixar aqui uma
boneca metimacumba aqui de lado só para
só para prevenir né eu não ligo muito
estas coisas mas vai que foi uma louco
que fez isto já agora vou tomar aqui a
caixa toda ó aqui tem uma mão
OK tá todo arrebentada aqui embaixo tem
uns arranhões aqui ó querem ok ok
está com cola quente
isto parece que tem dupla Uh tem um
plástico de boneca ainda ok ok
e tem tem sete aqui dentro tem sete aqui
dentro
Olha aí a boneca
tem aqui umas manchas de tinta tem um
saco com um bicho ali mano eu não sei eu
não sei mas estou curioso
aí a ela mexe os olhos
Mano eu tô destruir a caixa
o sistema foi com isto
tem uma chave nela
Isto é o quê orégano
dela
tem uma corda
calma calma calma calma
eu não sei eu vou virar bolsinha
primeiro eu quero ver a bolsa
Estou a gostar Ok Acabei de destruir o
inseto e Ah mas isso parecia-me uma
inseto a sério está-me a aparecer um
cara velho tá aqui Uma patinha dele
e é duro aqui dentro
cheiro é muito mal Inclusive só por eu
ter recebido isto em casa pessoal eu
quero abrir uma caixa postal também para
vocês me enviarem coisas assim escuto
receber as coisas à porta de casa né
abre uma caixa ui mano Isto é mesmo um
bicho puto ya Isto é mesmo um bicho Isto
é mesmo um inseto que está há quanto
tempo é que isto tem sete está aqui
tá cozido ah não tá nada Calma Olha
abriu abriu abriu Eu tô maluco Não tem
nada dentro
do lado eu estou a começar a sentir que
não é bom mexer nisso
que ela é assustadora é mas ao mesmo
tempo também é bonita mas eu não quero
deixar isto em minha casa por mais tempo
OK Tem mais alguma coisa aqui na caixa
parece que tem alguma coisa aqui atrás
Olha aí está bem
e só bolor Olha aí o mofo Olha é daqui
que vem um cheiro Man Olha o mofo que
tem aqui dentro
da cola porque
a gente tem qualquer coisa aqui dentro
a gente olhar assim
é que está a nossa boneca
temos um papel temos um papel agora que
eu vou descobrir Com certeza foi onde
você
Claro que sim eu já espetava 100% Olá
Dark viu teu vídeo da boneca assombrada
e gostei muito meu puto eu vou
jogar no euromi milhões caga Fizeste a
boneca Assombrada com meu amigo
Francisco Espero que espero que faças
vídeo dela também
Quem Martin eu não sei se devia revelar
ou não porque ele deixou que eu não me
completo calma eu sabia que
tinha sido um de vocês ok agora fico
mais aliviado foi o Martinho o Francisco
a fazer este vídeo depois de um ano ok
sorry já sabe como é que funciona aqui
um vídeo de 3 em 3 meses e é assim que
funciona aqui no canal Malta comentem
aqui neste vídeo arroz também nos
comentários se nós tivermos sem
comentários pelo menos a dizer arroz eu
coloco um vídeo por dia este mês Bora eu
acho que isto foi uma promessa ambiciosa
eu vou me lixar claro que vou mas é para
o meu bem e para o vós eia bem ela tem
uma caixa de som ela tem uma caixa de
som esta é daquela que mexe os olhos já
vimos isso
Malta reparem aqui
Olha aí Isto é daquelas bonecas antigas
que tinham aquela caixa de som bem na
lógica agora eu não sei se eu vou
conseguir arrancar isto se tem alguma
coisa ali dentro espera lá
eu vou tentar usar aqui o x exato
e é bem
eu não quero estragá-la esse é o
problema
o que é isto
Eu Nem percebo que mecanismo é este mas
tem aqui uma peça de metal
não é possível
em elástico
mecanismo antigo Olha aí anos 80
gostei
mapa para o Bruno aqui é que eu não
consigo abrir a boneca sem destruir
porque reparem ela tem aqui meio que a
costura né tipo Isto é colado Eu só
consigo abrir a boneca se eu destruir
eu sei que vou destruí-la portanto eu
nunca destruí-la olha e tem umas marcas
aqui também man agora eu não consigo
arrancar isto alguém me explica alguém
que precisa de bonecas antigas que
mecanismo É este aqui e se eu consigo
consertar isto mas com certeza ela fazer
algum tipo de ruído Porque isto de vibra
com certeza é que tem aqui um imã um
sistema que são qualquer antigo não faço
ideia mas que ela fazia som fazia
esta Chave É do quê
é de uma porta eu sei mas que porta que
porta
acho que não há nada mais né E tem
orelha e tudo olha aí orelha dela
boneca com orelha bem realista e nota-se
que ela usava brinco porque tem ali o
buraco ali do brinco Ok estão a brincar
Ok 1980 é que fazia boneca tem aqui já
uma careca
pronto era só isso
ó Martinho Mas tu tinhas aqui códigos
tenho aqui códigos nas pernas O que é
que isto faz
eu esperava algo mais agora esperava
algo mais Isto estava a ser muito
interessante e olhou o bolor da
bicharada aqui dentro
olha ali isto
eu gostava de ver mais agora mano vejam
como eram feitas as bonecas antigas isto
tem todo um elástico ali dentro
eu posso puxar e achei que estava a
aparecer de novo tá-me a aparecer que
foi substituído já mas é isso Pessoal
espero que tenham gostado aqui deste
unboxing inusitado Eh agora vou agarrar
neste dia a tirar para o lixo desculpa
Martinho Mas eu não quero mas a minha
casa ok e é isso pessoal deixem muito
like aqui neste vídeo comentem arroz se
eu tiver mais sem comentários a dizer
arroz Vamos fazer um vídeo por dia este
mês e é isso pessoal porta-se bem fiquem
bem até a próxima